hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV
we're in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and
we're talking to the Cato Institute's
vice president David bows thanks for
joining us thank you you just came from
a presentation where you were talking
about the libertarian view on Liberty a
gala tie and fraternity the rallying cry
of the French Revolution lay it on us
what what should libertarians think
about liberty as it was articulated by
the French revolutionaries well this is
the anniversary weekend of French
Revolution so we're talking a lot about
that here my view is that Mises and
Hayek talked about the ideas of 1789
they liked them the fundamental ideas if
you read them in the Declaration of the
Rights of Man are very good we are born
free and equal we have rights property
is inviolable now along with that you
can find other clauses in the
Declaration of the Rights of Man that
portends some problems references to the
general good and the sovereignty of the
nation and that tells you may be that
several people were involved in writing
this and isn't entirely consistent but
the fundamental idea the storming of the
Bastille on Jalan 14 was an indication
that they saw the on CN regime as an
absolutist regime of the church the
aristocracy the monarchy the
mercantilist and storming the Bastille
was a way of overthrowing that and
symbolically taking back freedom is it
taking back freedom or is it creating it
for the first time in a French contour a
European context well I think that our
view at least is people are born free
and equal so we're always free we have
to take back our frequent everywhere
we're in trance but well that that was
an illiberal riders interpretation a
liberal french writer Madame de style
said liberty is ancient in his despotism
that is modern so she did think going
back to the medieval world there was a
pre feudalist natural equality clearly
within the contemporary American
anglo-american
tarian movement the French Revolution
has an incredibly bad odor partly
because of the terror that came in its
wake but also because there remains a
kind of antagonism towards continental
or contemporary Europe and the French
state is seen as both snobby and
overbearing are we getting it wrong
there or are there things that we can
learn from the you know from from France
today that are worth worth applying I
think we're getting it partially wrong I
do think the spirit of overturning the
old order the on CN regime the rule of
the church and the King that was a good
liberal impulse that part was right the
confusion with the general will the
general good of the nation and so on
that part was bad and unfortunately that
part underlay a great deal of what
happened in the French Revolution and
beyond it's certainly true that their
revolution deteriorated into a reign of
terror and then Napoleon eventually
though they came out with a modern
democratic capitalist nation which is
better than the on CN regime that
preceded it can the United States learn
anything from France today I'm not sure
other than wine making & cheese making
well that would be a star would be good
you know some of the people in one of
the panels here's you know actually
asked the question are we headed towards
another American Revolution or another
French Revolution what's your sense of
things I mean you have been a long time
hand and political kind of observation
and political policy debates is this a
particularly crisis-ridden moment in the
American experiment we are always
talking about crisis in America but the
fact is i think that modern mixed
economy democracies are pretty stable
and it's very difficult for a Ronald
Reagan or a Barack Obama to make a big
difference in them and so much as I'd
like to see another American Revolution
I'm not necessarily betting on it we
have this huge overhanging death and
that's the best argument that there's
nothing we can do about that and we're
going to
end up with a crisis because of it but I
also remember 35 years ago when I was a
college student the first libertarian
Speaker I ever heard said we're going to
have hyperinflation by gold and guns
that's the only thing that'll save you
and our political system averted that
disaster and I suspect we'll find a way
to avert that disaster or maybe just to
push it off farther down the road and I
suspect it may include some inflation it
may include debt repudiation it may
include not being able to pay all the
promises governments have made but I'm
not convinced that we will have an
American Revolution of either kind
another thing that recurs in libertarian
thought is the idea that the youth are
inherently libertarian or that the this
next generation is purely libertarian we
talk a lot about this at reason people
at Cato do you know if you're born and
raised on the internet you're you you're
already living in a libertarian world do
you have any sense that youth today is
more libertarian than they were in the
past I do have a sense of that I also
remember that we thought when our
generation got to middle age surely
drugs would be legalized because come on
right and that hasn't happened there is
clearly a larger libertarian student
movement today than there ever has been
in modern America so that's a sign that
there's more libertarianism among
today's young people and I suspect that
today's young people generally are very
liberal on social issues racism is very
much a thing of the past anti-gay
attitudes very much a thing of the past
for young people question is what about
economic issues and I think young people
pretty well see that government isn't
any good at running the economy the
problem is they don't yet necessarily
see that the market is pretty good at
running itself so they're still looking
i mean they look at say something like
the housing collapse and then they don't
say amazoncom would have done this
better they recognized the government
screwed up but they don't trust
corporations well as sir I think that's
probably right i mean we're talking
about trying to
figure out what 20 million kids that
right yeah but yes I think there is an
understanding that the system isn't
working but not a good understanding if
there's an alternative system so we're
not out of jobs yet right yeah David
buzz vice president of the Cato
Institute thanks for talking to us thank
you for reason TV I'm Nicholas